GET THE IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL DONE?
THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT" ."
GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
WASHINGTON.
I AM SHANNON BREAM IN FOR
BRET BAIER.
FIRST LADY MELANIA TRUMP WAS
WITH HER HUSBAND THE PRESIDENT
THIS AFTERNOON FOR A BRIEFING
EARLIER IN THE DAY THE PRESIDENT
UNLEASHED A RHETORICAL
HURRICANE, RIPPING INTO THE
MEDIA FOR ITS COVERAGE OF HIS
WIFE.
THIS AFTERNOON, THE PRESIDENT
WAS IN A FORGIVING MOOD.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS HAS THAT TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING.
>> GOOD EVENING TOO.
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIAL TELLS
FOX NEWS THAT THE RECENT SPATE
OF PRESIDENTIAL PARDONS AND
COMMUTATIONS IS JUST THE
BEGINNING.
THE PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ACTIVELY
CONSIDERING ANOTHER HALF-DOZEN
WITH DOZENS MORE BEING REVIEWED
BY WHITE HOUSE STAFF.
>> WE HAD A SEASON LAST YEAR
LIKE NO OTHER IN TERMS OF THE
POWER, THE LEVEL, THE
HURRICANES, THE FIRES ALONG THE
WEST COAST.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP AT FEMA
HEADQUARTERS TODAY FOR HIS
ANNUAL REVIEW ON THE UPCOMING
HURRICANE SEASON, BUT IT WAS HIS
POWERS OF PRESIDENTIAL PARDON
THAT TOOK CENTER STAGE TODAY.
THE WHITE HOUSE ANNOUNCING
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S COMMUTING THE
SENTENCE OF ALICE MARIE JOHNSON.
LAST WEEK, KIM KARDASHIAN CALLED
ON THE PRESIDENT TO ASK HIM TO
PARDON JOHNSON, A
GREAT-GRANDMOTHER WHO HAS BEEN
JAILED SINCE 1996 ON A
NONVIOLENT DRUG CHARGE.
IT FELL SHORT OF A FULL PARDON
BUT THE WHITE HOUSE PRAISED
JOHNSON REHABILITATION, SAYING
"MS. JOHNSON HAS ACCEPTED
RESPONSIBILITY FOR PAST BEHAVIOR
AND HAS BEEN A MODEL PRISONER
OVER THE PAST TWO DECADES."
>> I WOULD LIKE TO START OFF.
MAYBE SAY AND PAY SOME RESPECT
TO SOME OF THE PEOPLE HERE
TODAY.
I HAVE A LIST.
WE HAVE TO START WITH OUR GREAT
FIRST LADY, MELANIA.
THANK YOU, MELANIA.
>> AT THE PRESIDENT'S SIDE
DURING THE BRIEFING, FIRST LADY
MELANIA TRUMP, THE FIRST TIME
SHE HAS BEEN SEEN ON CAMERA
SINCE A MEDICAL PROCEDURE
MAY 14.
>> A LITTLE ROUGH PATCH BUT SHE
IS DOING GREAT AND WE ARE VERY
PROUD OF HER.
SHE HAS DONE A FANTASTIC JOB AS
FIRST LADY.
THE PEOPLE OF OUR COUNTRY LOVE
YOU.
SO THANK YOU, HONEY.
>> THE FIRST LADY WAS OUT OF
PUBLIC VIEW FOR 22 DAYS,
PROMPTING SPECULATION THAT
SOMETHING WAS AMISS.
AHEAD OF TODAY'S APPEARANCE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAMMERING THE
SPECULATION, TWEETING:
"THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA HAS BEEN SO
UNFAIR, AND VICIOUS, TO MY WIFE
AND OUR GREAT FIRST LADY,
MELANIA.
DURING HER RECOVERY FROM SURGERY
THEY REPORTED EVERYTHING FROM
NEAR DEATH, TO FACELIFT,
TO LEFT THE W.H. AND ME
FOR N.Y. OR VIRGINIA, TO ABUSE.
ALL FAKE, SHE IS DOING REALLY
WELL!"
>> SECRETARY NIELSEN, WHAT DO I
SAY ABOUT YOU?
YOU ARE DOING GREAT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO
SPREADING A LITTLE LOVE FOR
CABINET MEMBERS ON THE FRONT
LINES OF DISASTER RESPONSE AND
THROWING A BIG BONE TO HIS
EMBATTLED EPA ADMINISTRATOR
SCOTT PRUITT.
>> ADMINISTRATOR SCOTT PRUITT,
THANK YOU.
EPA IS DOING REALLY, REALLY WELL
EPA IS DOING REALLY, REALLY WEL
WELL.
SOMEBODY HAS TO SAY THAT ABOUT
YOU A LITTLE BIT.
YOU KNOW THAT.
>> PRUITT COME ALONG UNDER
SCREENING FOR LAVISH SPENDING
AND SECURITY DEMANDS, WAS MOST
RECENTLY UNDER FIRE FOR ASKING
AN AID TO CONTACT CHICK-FIL-A
ABOUT A POSSIBLE FRANCHISE FOR
HIS WIFE AND FOR ASKING AN AID
TO LOOK INTO WHETHER HE COULD
BUY A USED MATTRESS FROM THE
TRUMP INTERNATIONAL HOTEL.
>> PEOPLE ARE REALLY IMPRESSED
WITH YOUR JOB BEING DONE AT THE
EPA.
THANK YOU, SCOTT.
>> TWO TOP AIDES TO PRUITT
ANNOUNCED THEY WERE RESIGNING.
THE AID THAT PRUITT ASKED TO TRY
TO PROCURE THE USED MATTRESS
FROM THE TRUMP HOTEL
ANNOUNCED SHE'S GOING TO BE
LEAVING FRIDAY.
ACCORDING TO PUBLISHED REPORTS,
SHE GOT TIRED OF PRUITT THROWING
HER UNDER THE BUS AND SEEING HER
NAME IN PRINT.
THE OTHER OFFICIAL TO BE LEAVING
IS REPORTEDLY SARAH GREENWALD,
TOP ATTORNEY THERE.
ONE OF PRUITT'S CLOSEST ADVISORS
ONE OF PRUITT'S CLOSEST ADVISOR
ADVISORS.
BOTH GREENWALD AND HUFF WERE IN